let's do some data sufficiency problems
so the first problem problem number 1 on
page 278 it says how much is 20% of a
certain number so we want to know what
20% of a number let me just call that X
so what is that
so the first data point they give us is
that 10% of the number is 5 so we could
say that is 10% times X is equal to 5
another way we could just write that is
point 1 X is equal to 5 and then the
second data point I guess we could call
it is 40% of twice the number is equal
to 40 so 40% 0.4 times twice the number
so times 2 X right we chose X as our
number is equal to 40 so what we have to
figure out is do either of these data
points allow us to figure out extra -
maybe we need both of them or maybe we
can't figure out even with all of this
information well this is a simple a
simple linear equation right very easy
way to think about it is you could
multiply both sides of this by 2 both
sides equation and you end up with 0.2
times X is equal to 10 well that's the
same thing as saying that 20% of X is
equal to 10 so statement 1 alone is is
all we need to figure out this let's see
if what statement 2 gets us so if we
simplify this expression just a little
bit we get let's see point 4 times two
we have 0.8 times X is equal to 40 and
here instead of multiplying both sides
of this equation by 2 we could divide
both sides by 4 right because we want to
get 20 percent of X this is 80% of X so
if we divide both sides of this by 4 we
get 1 we get point 2 X is equal to
ten there you go 20% of X is equal to
ten so either of these alone are enough
to solve that problem and I always
forget what the letters aren't but I
think that is I think that is statement
well I'll leave it for you to figure it
out I know there's a statement that's
statement D each statement alone is
sufficient
all right problem number two I don't
want to waste too much time on that
problem number two and I'm trying to do
this in real time without looking at the
answers because I really want you to get
a sense of how someone thinks about this
if they've never seen the problem before
and so I'll ask you to bear with me a
little bit because maybe I'll get a
problem wrong and maybe that'll be
instructive if I do okay they say a
thoroughly blended biscuit mix includes
only flour and baking powder flour and
baking powder baking powder what is the
ratio of the number of grams of baking
powder to the number of grams of flour
so we want to know this if we want
another ratio of baking powder to flour
that's what they we need to figure out
now statement number one they tell us
exactly nine point nine grams of flour
is contained in ten grams of the myth
mix so they're nine point nine flour how
much and there's exactly ten how much
how much baking powder is there well
baking powder is going to be equal to 10
minus the amount of flour so it's going
to be what point 1 grams right nine
point we could say that that is equal to
flour so we could easily just using this
first statement figure out the ratio
write the ratio of baking powder to
flour is 0.1 we just took 10 minus the
amount of flour 29.9 or you could say
it's 1 to 99 whatever however you need
it but that's what's fun about this film
you don't have to figure it out we just
have to say we could figure it out so 1
is enough by itself let's see what
statement 2 tells us statement 2 and
I'll do it in a slightly different color
statement 2 says let me scroll down a
little bit
statement two says exactly 0.3 gram I
think I think that's an error in the
book it should be grams exactly 0.3 gram
of baking powder is contained in 30
grams of the mix so if we have 0.3
baking powder baking powder that's grams
so and it says that tells us there's 30
grams of the mix so how much flour do we
have well it's 30 30 minus 0.3 is equal
to what is equal to twenty nine point
seven twenty nine point seven flour and
so once again we can easily figure out
the ratio of baking powder to flour its
0.32 twenty nine point seven which is
once again one two ninety nine but we
didn't even have to figure that out we
just know that this is enough so once
again we know that D each statement
alone is sufficient unless I miss
something
all right problem number three problem
three let me scroll down a little bit
what is the value of the absolute value
of x so they want to know the absolute
value of X is equal to what and the
first statement they tell us the first
statement they tell us is that X is
equal to the minus absolute value of X
so what what numbers is this true for
that the number is equal to the minus
absolute value it's definitely not true
for positive numbers right I'm going to
put a positive one there one is not
equal to the absolute value of 1 is 1 so
1 is not equal to negative 1 this works
for 0 right 0 is equal to negative 0 is
equal to 0 and this works for negative
numbers try it out negative 1 right
negative 1 is equal to the negative
absolute value of negative 1 well the
absolute value negative 1 is 1 so you
get negative 1 is equal to negative 1 so
it works for 0 and negative number so
that all this tells us and maybe maybe
this will help us in conjunction with
the second part who knows this just
tells us that X is less than or equal to
0 it's just a convoluted way of saying
this let's see what it where that gets
us now the second statement
second statement let's see they say that
x squared is equal to four x squared is
equal to four well this tells us that X
is equal to plus or minus two now if we
were if we were trying to figure out
what X is equal to we would actually
need both of these statements because
this statement says oh X is positive 2
or negative 2 and then this statement
says that oh X is definitely negative so
if we were trying to figure out what the
value of x was we would need both of
these statements but notice they're
asking us what's the value of the
absolute value of x all right
so regardless of whether X is positive
or negative 2 the absolute value of
either positive or negative 2 is always
going to be equal to 2 so really this is
all you need you only need statement two
to figure out this problem and so that
is B you only need statement two all
right I think I got that one right let's
see problem number what am i on problem
number four I'll do it in this brownish
color problem number four is R greater
than 0.2 seven very simple question is
are greater than 0.2 seven they asked ok
statement one tells us that R is greater
than one-fourth okay well that doesn't
really ya mean R could still be you know
this is 0.25 so R could still be equal
to 0.25 one right it could be 0.25 1 or
it could be 0.3 so this really doesn't
give us any information that we don't
know whether R is greater than 0.2 7
let's see the second statement tells us
second statement says R is equal to 3/10
R is equal to three tens well that is
equal to 0.3 and that's definitely
greater than 0.2 7 so this is all we
need
we just need statement to statement 1
was a little useless so and that is I
always forget what letters that's B we
only need we only need statement - all
right how am i doing on time oh I have
time I think I can do a couple more
problems these go fast you don't have to
actually do the math
problem number five what is the value of
the sum of a list of n odd integers so
sum of n odd integers okay and they
didn't say consecutive and they didn't
say where it starts it's just an odd
integers fair enough okay one they say
tell us that n is equal to eight
so if I knew that I was going to sum
eight odd integers can I know the sum
well I know I mean it though it could be
you know these all of these could be the
numbers in the millions right there or
they could be you know negative well or
they could be you know really small
numbers so that doesn't help me much
point number two they say the square of
the integers on the list is 64 so
they're essentially saying that N
squared is equal to 64 and since we're
talking about numbers and lists it can't
be negative so n is equal to 8 so these
are really telling me the same thing
just this is a little bit more confident
but really they don't help out I mean I
could have eight numbers in the billions
or I could have eight numbers in in the
hundreds and so I'm obviously going to
get a different sum so I don't think I
can figure this out anyway so that's
what that is statement e o that's e that
they're together are not sufficient so
that's so neither both of these are
useless I still don't know the answer
which is e all right well I think I'm
out of time I just passed the 10-minute
mark I will continue in the next video
see you soon